have you always been obsessive about
your career right yes I think you need
to be somewhat obsessive in a healthy
way you have to have a healthy ego to be
in this business you have to know you're
good in order to succeed in this
business if you don't believe that
you're good you know then you've got to
go do something else because you're
going to get hit time and time again
about how you look you know you're this
you're that you're too old you're too so
you have to have a thick skin and yeah I
you know just actually I was periscoping
with somebody in the car before this and
I said I was doing this interview and
this guy goes okay get me into the
business and I said get yourself into
the business look like cause it's hard
work you know um he's like I want to be
an actor and I said well unless you are
an actor and you are a hundred and ten
percent don't do it because it's tough
again I've had a long beautiful resume
but it's still hard even to this day I
have a movie coming out next year but
also I haven't worked in almost a year
so it's like you have to be able to
sustain yourself somehow through this
business and you know it's tough so yeah
you have to you have to be obsessive to
a healthy degree you know you don't want
to be unhealthy which is the other way
around and tearing yourself down because
as actors I think we are our own worst
enemy you know it's much easier to be
loving and inviting to somebody else but
how are you to towards yourself and as
actors man all of our our emotions are
on on the level on the skin level right
here they're always accessible so you
know it's a daily I think um thing to
remind yourself that you got to love
yourself and you got to push yourself in
this business
and don't become complacent it's
interesting so with with loving yourself
do you find that there are things
outside of the business that you can
focus on when maybe stuff dries up for a
little bit which I know it happens for
every afternoon and then all of a sudden
all these projects come at the same time
so there're other things outside of the
business that maybe you can focus on and
then yeah I I say follow your passions
no matter where they lead no matter what
they are
I you know I've been acting for a long
time who I am but I also started
paranormal investigating which I do
relentlessly it's also become a religion
for me in a way it's kind of how I a
spirituality I should say it's not
religion this is something I've been
doing for God seven years now and I go
out and and Perrineau investigate now I
lead tours myself and sort of help
facilitate conversations between the
living and the dead I did a show called
go stalkers where they they put me in
another guy named John Tenney out who's
really haunted places and left us alone
overnight by myself home so yeah and now
that's you know another passion of mine
that has helped sort of fill up the the
times when I'm not working as an actor I
do tons of investigations I lead people
now and take them out to really haunted
places and so it's good fun it's
interesting I know what intuition we all
have it but some people have it more two
different degrees or they can develop it
more was it something that you always
had from the time you were little I
think so I think so I've always been a
very open person
I had a Hadiya disease and I was younger
caller ID syndrome and it's a taxi
immune system and remember doctors said
basically told my parents he's going to
die within a few hours go say goodbye
and I was maybe 7 maybe at the time and
I was expected to die and I think in
that period of time because I was
bedridden for about two months and not
two months excuse me two weeks in the
hospital I kind of floated in and out
a sort of kind of went back and forth
what did that had something to do with
me being open and being able to see
ghosts and hear them I don't know I
don't know and then there were other
kids in that hospital that died and I
lived so I don't know if I had anything
to do with me being open near-death
experiences I do believe open people up
in a way that probably they needed
something happens like that you have to
look at it like and I know this is going
way off of acting on it yeah but you
know it all plays into each other I
think when you have a near-death
experience we need to look at that as an
awakening experience and how can we do
that use that to awaken dream being
intuitive I know probably pickup hits
about whether it's a place whether it's
a person how much do you say because
sometimes as intuitive people we have to
learn to keep our mouths shut because
we're we know things or we at least we
feel we do but maybe it's not our place
to say them in the course of your
day-to-day life because you have this
ability it's one thing if you go into an
area but let's suppose you're in LA and
LA is is sometimes not the place to be
the most brutally honest but but I think
as being a person that has sort of
somebody that they're answering to
that's maybe your consciousness about
you maybe I'm not describing right when
you filter yourself because I know it's
a problem of a lot of intuitive people
um I try to fill I mean usually
something will happen and then I'll be
like light drums at or I was thinking
about this person you know and then
you'll get a phone call or something
like that so I think we're all tied in
in some weird way and we have to and
again it ties into acting we need to pay
attention to our intuition you know I
think a lot of time will that nagging
feeling will come up about something and
we don't listen to it
you know then something happens like oh
we should listen to that you know so
yeah you know if there's something that
I feel like needs to be said I'll say
but I think a lot of I think there's a
lot of psychics or mediums or however
you want to say that put forth that
information without being asked and I
don't think that's the right thing you
know usually if somebody says all I'm
like this I'm like that I don't think
you are
hey you know what I mean if you have to
tell somebody that you're this you know
kawaman actor mama bass some of that I
don't know that you are because if you
really are do you have to say you know
what I mean you have to validate
yourself actually I can hear that a lot
in this town especially sure I think
that's really interesting then when
you're in a scene with them because if
you let's just I'm into saying without
putting a label on it just being extra
sensitive to energy right how is that
that must be amazing
or but it could also be interesting if
maybe there's friction how do you how do
you deal with that emotion because I
know a lot of people that are very
sensitive it's a lot of stimuli that
comes out them well when you're acting I
feel like you got to use whatever
stimuli whatever stimuli you can grab on
to to sort of like get you into a scene
I remember working on sons of anarchy
and I had known a couple of the guys on
the set and I did a guest start and then
halfway through the day
um I walked over to where they were all
kind of hanging out and I won't mention
which one of the guys but he goes get
out of here this isn't your scene I was
like like dude get out of here
this isn't your scene and we were about
to do a scene together and I was like
hurt you know and like a couple of
actors they were like oh don't worry
about it okay
you know don't don't don't take it
personally so I walked away and I was
like you know and then it got me going
you know and then I used it in the scene
and then back up my butt and you get
there so it worked not something I would
do to another actor however
you know however it comes out sometimes
you got to take it there in order to go
somewhere else
you